[Music]
I sent you the royal wedding simple
instructions
don't cause an international incident
how's it going
you've done some pretty stupid things in
your day but this thanks for the cake
Henry shoved me an urge I currently
shared
what I need is some good old-fashioned
damage control
the White House and the palace are going
to release a joint statement
you've got to be choking you can hate
Prince Henry all you want Mandy is
bigger than yours I want you to know
that they're wearing lifts no not too
sweetheart you better act like the
Sunshine's out of his ass and you have a
vitamin D deficiency I think excellent
is what you might say to convince the
world that we're actually friends I love
hanging out with this guys
[Music]
you're expecting at my New Year's party
I do something wrong you don't wonder
who you'd be if you were an anonymous
person in the world I have no idea what
you're talking about
[Music]
your majesty it's your Royal Highness
dear Alex I miss you
we are in a hotel crawling with
reporters if anyone sees you leave this
hotel I will brexit your head from your
body your Royal Highness
figure out if you 've forever about him
do you love him one difference for the
man if I did
Prince Henry belongs to Britain we can
figure out a way to love each other on
our own terms it's like there's a rope
attached to my chest and keeps pulling
me towards you
hopefully we'll get to tonight without
any more scandals
the night is young Ma
[Music]